foreign
Casey joins us in Phoenix Arizona Casey
Aqua we hope
hi guys hey
I recently made a decision that felt
like I had to make
my mom she has a way of making me feel
like I'm doing something wrong unless
it's not the way she's doing it
so did you say you had to make this
decision
I felt I felt like I had to and you know
I'm working on that with myself his mom
made her feel it right how old are you
Casey yeah how am I and how old am I I'm
28. Casey just turned 28. the 9th of
February Casey you're a grown woman
and you know your girl I know like you
have got to get to the point where you
get over disappointing your mom because
based on what you said and the way
you're acting I believe you 100 and I'm
just gonna say something that may hurt
your feelings when you need to hear it
your mom is manipulating you
yeah yeah
she doesn't get to do that anymore
she's going to love you even when you
disappoint her because you've been a
really good girl growing up and you're a
pretty great lady as an adult true or
false
or or she might not we don't know the
mom and boundaries are still healthy
fair you know what that's a very good
point but my I just I don't think that
do you and you and your mom have a
fairly healthy relationship outside of
this kind of stuff
you know one thing I wish is that my
parents were more of financial
awareness with amongst us too and
growing up I'm suffering with that so
tell us did everything the wrong way so
tell us this financial decision that you
felt pressured into
okay well I'll take it back to October
October
debt free you know I'm peaceful mind I'm
feeling good I I drive a clunker it's
but it's getting by I have a credit card
though because my mom
said you know you got to start credit
somehow if we get a credit card okay
fine but I'm going to be better with it
I don't want to be like Mom and have all
this credit debt so I pay it all off I
pay it currently today after listening
and you know trying to do my research I
don't need the credit card so I canceled
it today because you have a zero balance
yay so I felt good about that it felt
really good we gotta hurry up because we
only got about two minutes with you so
how much what's the car situation
November lost my car November lost my
clunker I got a car loan
I have a car loan now it's 13 Grand I
don't feel good about it mom says I
should have got a higher car I should
have got it better yeah we don't care
what mom says anymore on this issue
what's the car worth so I have it the
cars
13k I bought it for 12 I got uh the
extended warranty for 29 I put four
grand down so now it sits at 13 one I
haven't even had a first payment yet due
the 25th what is the car worth could you
sell it today what could you sell it for
I I don't know I just got it I literally
just bought it from the dealership so
this is your only debt this is your only
debt correct this is my this is my only
bet I have about 12 and a half in in
cash in the bank I have 44 of my
emergency funds I just lowered my 401k
to three percent should I turn the 401K
off and put everything to this car can I
pay off this car tomorrow so I don't
know what that'll do to the bank because
I've never just you know
so I'm gonna let Christina answer
because we've got about a minute left so
pay attention she's going to walk you
through this so you said you have 12 000
in the bank and the loan is 13 000. is
that correct I got her on hold because
we're about to run into brakes yeah it
sounds like you have the cash she's
mentioned another 44 so it's like if you
have the cash right now I want you to
pay it off don't borrow from your 401k
loan I couldn't tell she was trying to
hint at that she's saying should I pause
401k contribution to pay it off yes
normally yes but I think you can pay
this completely off by my math it was 9
000 you owe you got 12 plus another four
pay it off today today and then be debt
free go get yourself a cheap three
thousand four thousand and we're gonna
gift you FPU we want you to take it and
stop listening to Mom look this is your
financial Journey yes